You were like,
no,
no.
Well I'm going to do this.
In fact,
you probably didn't even work in the middle of it.
Were you even thinking,
Dang,
this is going long.
Were you ever thinking that it was until afterwards,
like Dang,
that was a long,
yeah.
That's awesome.
That's a good symptom.
Good.
I'm happy about that.
Camera one is about to start rolling.
Gotcha.
Where it is.
I don't feel like wearing headphones today.
Do you want the diva?
No,
no,
no.
It's all good.
No,
no,
no.
Like I don't feel like,
I just feel like you're getting her like Dang,
no time for even putting on the headphones.
Just so fucking task,
uh,
oriented,
saturated and unsaturated.
Ah,
at these books,
they're all different.
Totally different.
There's no book like this,
by the way.
I liked that book already.
Like remember they get the book,
Mind Games,
I always talk about it's,
it's similar.
This is probably like more,
it might be significant,
but um,
I can give him,
it was a lot like that.
I liked it.
You're going to clap this thing out because I'm ready to rock and roll.
If you're regular?
No.
You're hitting rock and roll.
Do I look smaller?
Yeah.
Did you,
are you just cutting weight right now?
I'm not putting,
I just thought I'd been doing Jujitsu.
Not as much lifting and then the little pitch,
I was thinking about this today while I was squatting fucking heavy,
sir.
You don't swap do you?
I do.
Oh,
you do?
I do.
Like front.
It's like,
but you don't have fucking,
you don't have a squat rack at your house.
No.
So I use like kettlebell stuff in that kind of,
no,
I don't do that.
Don't give a fuck man squat back squat overhead squat.
No,
you're not in there just fucking getting fucking crazy.
What?
Squats none anymore.
But you used to buy all the truth.
Paul used to fucking know,
even though after football when I was into lifting,
even with Jujitsu,
but oh yeah.
Fucking Bra.
How deep?
Not as deep as go now.
Okay.
It's called,
what do you call it?
Parallel.
Parallel squat.
Yeah.
That's the official standard for football is okay.
Oh,
all right,
bro.
Keep not good enough.
I'm good enough.
Okay.
No,
no,
no.
Okay.
That's the standard.
So this is,
this is where it is.
This is why I left one of those things.
You're like,
would you have to explain that I hate because you're rolling your eyes and your
eyes,
you know.
Well,
at least you know the difference.
I do know the difference,
the difference between going fucking all the way down.
Yeah.
And going parallel.
So there's a big difference.
Huge difference.
Big Difference.
Agree.
Hundreds of pounds potentially,
you know,
maybe,
maybe 10,
a hundred,
150 pounds depending even that,
there's a huge,
huge caveat to huge.
Can't get to the point that it's beyond a caveat.
This is,
it's whatever you're used to.
So here and do this,
do this and you can do this applies to bench squat,
whatever.
So you know how,
um,
like right now let's say like a leg routine is like a kettlebell routine.
And then I'll,
do you know how you rack the two kettlebells?
Yeah.
And you do squats,
front squats all the way down.
Yeah.
So I got pretty,
I'm pretty used to that now to go all the way down as far as he can
and I'm pretty flexible by the way in that way.
If I were to start going just to parallel right now,
it would be harder because whenever you get used to and try that with bench.
So when I used to bench all the way down in touch.
Cool.
And then you know,
I got pretty strong in bench.
Then I see guys,
they're like,
you shouldn't touch,
you should be like an inch.
And some guys were even mind like two,
three inches.
So I was like,
Oh fuck,
that's easier.
I go all the way down and get the stretch.
What?
That's easier.
They're like,
you're going to let up pounds.
Yeah,
sometimes.
Sure.
But not all the time.
I'll still even,
even if even if you're doing no bounce,
you're still getting a little mounds,
right?
I mean like yeah,
your pins are getting like a little chicken.
Get back after you pens.
Yeah,
sometimes.
Sure.
But that's not the point.
The point is I'd still,
I'd go try it.
I was like,
fuck.
It's way easier.
I can do more.
I do my same weight in its way or you're right,
you're right.
Because
I am used to doing deep squats for so long that when I try like the box squats
or whatever,
but it definitely feels,
it feels harder.
It's harder.
Yeah,
for sure.
You're correct.
And I stopped doing squats.
I'm admin out of slight bit of laziness.
Right?
Cause when,
and this was like when I was like,
this is old,
like when I was a blue belt and I stopped kind of doing like a bunch of legs.
You rationalize it.
Yeah.
So basically but,
but successfully.
So when I stopped it and you know you're my leg and I remember Sarah,
he's always telling me this like when we'd be laying down,
you know,
you lay down on the bed or whatever,
you skip leg day.
No,
no she'd say the opposite.
She's like,
look how big your legs are right now cause you hot.
Like I have skinny knees,
you know,
skinny ankles,
you know like so you don't know.
You think maybe get a wasting.
But one my,
one of my shorts kind of fall and you see the muscle part,
you know,
it's surprisingly big.
What do you mean?
Like if you're laying down like this,
oh I see what you're saying.
Your short fall down,
fall up,
up.
Technically we'll soul say whatever.
Yeah,
so they fall in reveal.
So that's what she say she be,
look how big your legs or something like cool.
I'm like,
yeah,
they're huge.
But I didn't say that but so later on when I stopped kind of doing like heavy
squats all the time and I was doing Jujitsu,
I could do way more like the leg,
like Moo,
like triangle chokes were way easier and strangely like even going for armbars
and transitioning from the bottom and stuff became like a lot more easy.
Hey look,
I understand as time goes on you get better at these things.
Could have been that,
but it seemed a lot easier.
So it's like this is all I'm going to,
you know,
do it.
Yeah.
Big Time.
But thing is,
it's always worked for me.
Yeah,
whatever bro.
All right.
Still
kept doing curls though.
So Kevin,
see obviously you'll get they got the guns to prove that one.
Isn't that funny though.
How like skipping leg days,
this fun kind of fun thing to like why don't they say that about skipping arms
today?
Cause everyone no one skips army.
No,
but that's what I mean like day hurts.
I like it is hard.
Yeah I guess so.
Well I was thinking that,
that's why I was thinking about this today cause I was squatting.
I was like I wonder if,
cause I was thinking to myself like you never talk about squatting.
Yeah.
And I'm thinking myself,
I wonder if echo even squats.
Yeah.
Devens cause you've got skinny knees.
Yeah he's giddy ankles.
See but see what I mean now you're like all laughing.
Like why is that funny?
I have skinny wrists too.
I think it's funny that you said you had skidded me.
Know what that means.
First step skinny me damn boat.
Stand up.
I'll tell us fucking shot.
Uh
Yeah I'll see you about that today.
Cause anyway cause you know,
cause
you know squats like I was getting taxed today like I was,
I was getting beat down by squats Monday morning.
It's hot in my garage.
The weights are heavy.
I was trying up Italy.
If you ever see me get out the little two and a halfs and put them on like I'm
just trying to push it a little bit.
I did that today and I will do that and I was getting beat down and I was
thinking I'm getting beat down.
Does that wait was,
I was like this is like proof,
right?
Like it takes a,
takes a certain level of fortitude if you're going to keep going.
I'm,
I'm being straight up w the one workout,
there's one work they got all the hardcore,
the,
the big metcons and all those.
None of those are anything to me compared to like heavy squat day where you're
going,
this is the thing.
High Rep heavy squats.
Yeah.
Like 20 rep squats.
I'm sure you've heard of this workout.
20 rep squats.
It's,
and you're doing,
we use it,
wait,
that you can do 10 times and you do it 20 times.
No know you'll try to,
well you do it and it's a nightmare.
It almost,
I'm not kidding,
it almost makes me cry.
It almost makes a tear form up in my non shooting.
And so as I was doing that today,
I was like,
yeah,
well I'm not going to tear up in my,
you know,
my shooting guy.
No,
you got stuff to do.
So,
so I was thinking as I was going through this pain,
I was like,
think of myself,
I wonder if echo actually does this.
Cause this is super hardcore.
I'm honored by the way.
And no,
we shouldn't be,
because I was actually questioning,
I wasn't like damn all,
I wasn't like,
Echo does this too.
I was kind of like an echo muscle,
not on the grid.
So it's all good.
Yeah.
And,
and then the fact is you did squat.
If you're squatting heavyweights,
like you worry.
That's,
that's,
yeah.
Yeah.
And I know that I know the pain situation.
Sure.
And,
uh,
you did give up on them.
Yes.
Oh and I'm in.
Yeah,
I mean technically,
I mean squat and they,
come on,
let's face it,
that's a macho thing to be like,
oh,
you don't squat.
I'm not even that strong.
That's,
that's one of the,
that's one of the jacked up things in and it just like,
I'm not like one of these guys,
like I see the guys that are winning crossfit right now.
It's guys are freaking destroyers.
Dude,
those guys are just snatching insane amount of weights.
I mean like,
yeah,
I can't do that.
You can't compare it.
That's like saying fucking my mile time sucks still these college fucking track
athletes,
they're my,
you know,
it's like you're,
you're like saying you're a sucks compared to the best guys,
you know,
kind of thing.
So that's true.
But it does still does suck.
Cause like I lift weights.
Yeah.
I don't run,
I think you're strong.
Well,
well let's go into the numbers.
Yeah.
But I'm not,
I'm not saying,
oh,
you know,
hey,
I'm,
I'm trying to run.
If I was trying to run a four minute mile,
then I'd be saying,
Dang,
these guys are so much better than me,
but I'm not.
So I'm not saying that.
Oh,
but you're trying to train these,
trying to be like a little bit stronger.
Can you normal,
what do you,
what do you walk around at?
You wait,
uh,
two 30.
Okay.
So two 30 squat.
Let's save for a set of 10 if you're getting two 30 if you can get four or five
for 10 that's like good,
good.
I think.
Yeah,
I'd say I'd say,
um,
if not,
they're a little below there.
Yeah.
That's good.
That's a good squat.
Like the king good.
Like,
like Dang.
That's a good squat.
I'd say less than good.
Like I think 10 would hurt me.
Yeah.
So like you were array,
but either way,
that's good.
So if even if you were to go three wheels,
four 10,
that's still good.
It's good.
But it's like,
okay,
it's not impressive,
but it's like,
it's,
I'd say that's fine.
That's a big difference between four or five and three 15 though.
Yeah.
That's a big difference.
Like,
like three 15 I'm here all the way down though.
I think that,
I mean sure,
you're used to it.
Good.
Good for you.
Congratulations on the home.
But like when I,
I was like two 42 40 and I was doing four wheels,
four 12 that was my first step.
That's all legit.
Yeah.
But it wasn't,
all right.
All the way down is two parallel.
But you know,
like I said,
I don't know,
I was always like,
oh yeah,
I was parallel.
But it's really hard to tell.
You know what I mean?
Well,
I'm not trying to say you were cheating,
but yeah,
that's true.
But in my,
in my set number,
rep number five was guy didn't get it.
Rep number seven was a little bit off.
Yeah.
Maybe.
But in my eye,
if anyone's going to get the correct formance me because in football they,
they care about that stuff.
You know when you test and you tee I think like twice a year,
fall and spring,
you test your all your wage to do 25 how many reps did you do that for?
Bench.
Yeah.
That's like the big combine.
So when I was playing football,
when a weed,
one 80 I did 17 that's awesome.
Yes.
I was one ed show.
Yeah,
it was.
It was the best one.
You played football.
You you're only one 80 yes.
Oh,
the wide receivers.
Your heaviest.
Well,
I started getting a little bit heavier.
Yeah.
Oh,
one 90 maybe.
It was my heavier,
wicked fast day.
I was like on,
I ran for aid.
The same level athlete.
You guys are the same.
He was heavier than me.
You guys are the same level like athletically.
Yeah.
More or less.
He beat me in the 200 meter.
I beat him in the 100 meter dash even though even though he was heavier than
you.
Oh yeah.
That's weird.
That's reversed,
right?
To what the instinct would be.
Yeah.
Maybe the intuitive thought would be if you're heavier,
you beat him on the hundred and he beats you on the 200 yeah.
What was your 40 times four,
four,
seven consistently like more than one kind of timer.
Uh,
electronics.
I don't know about electronic.
Yeah.
Well
that's life man.
Keep in mind,
this is in the nineties so,
Hey,
what are you,
what are you going to go?
I did two 25 33 times after football day on those bigger though.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
I thought it was pretty solid.
Yeah.
I don't,
I haven't had benched in solar.
Came in until you seriously right now.
Like I remember Alan benched in a long time.
Yeah,
I'm with you.
And I benched just to see how we'd feel and it's weird.
I feel like all stiff and like Kinda kinda awkward.
Really.
Yeah.
And I could probably do 25 probably 15 times.
Mainly right now 15 times.
Yeah.
Cause with dumbbells I can do my first set with one fifteens pound dumbbells and
I can do 1212 pretty easy like that.
Like if I were to like go all out,
I could probably get like maybe 16 of those,
maybe even more with one 15 on an incline to,
by the way,
I don't do flat anymore until like afterwards,
you know,
and flat is strong decline.
No.
Remember decline used to be like you go ahead.
Yeah,
you can go heavier because it's less range of motion and yeah,
but no,
I've never known.
Never got into that.
That's a weird exercise.
Decline bench.
Yeah.
But yeah,
I think um,
yeah,
but the squat thing,
why is that funny though?
I'm not saying just to you.
I think it's funny too,
you know when it's like,
oh they're good.
Skipped leg.
Like you ever seen a guy with big legs and he can squat and he can clean and
this guy's legit.
Like you kind of have this like Dang,
But then he's like week on top.
Wow.
How come no one teases that guy?
Cause he got strong laggers.
Yeah,
I know Dave.
No that's true.
Because on,
I mean let's face it.
That looks kind of funny too.
Yeah.
But they don't,
they don't teach that.
But are you sensitive about this?
Not enough sensing like,
well you laughed pretty hard earlier.
I was for laughing at the whole situation.
Going back to you said you had skinny that did stand up right now.
Stand up right now.
That did kind of cracked me up.
Yeah.
See how you see how your knees are a we'll say about here.
Oh Damn.
Like I'm skinny,
skinny ankles.
That's how you know what the genetic things should you when we wrote like look
at your fucking receiving,
see how your and your,
I would say yours are thicker than the average person,
but they're not as thick as deans all.
Yeah,
like grandma and I didn't know like I have pretty big muscles.
I understand.
Oh,
so mine's a little bit bigger than the others in that I thought they would be.
You know what's funny though,
I have,
I have noticed this and if you would have had to hypnotize me,
bring me like back into,
uh,
into the recesses of my mind and if you would've drilled down into the recesses
of my mind under hypnotism.
Yeah.
Hitting those hip under hypnosis you would have found and you would've said,
what is an interesting characteristics characteristic of echos ankles when you
ankle lock them.
I'd been like,
Oh yeah,
you're going to break.
He's got little skinny ankles.
And when I just looked at him,
I was like,
oh,
that's right.
I remember that because when I don't,
I don't go for your feet a lot,
but I remember when I have gone for them,
I've been like,
oh yeah,
this shit.
You ain't got much going on here.
Yeah.
I,
yeah,
the resistance and I felt bad,
feel bad or not bad,
but for myself,
you know?
Yeah.
Like Dean,
I'm like trying to do a fucking straight foot lock on him,
and he was like,
Whoa,
dude.
And I'm like,
freaking,
why can't I do like that,
bro?
Dean is a fucking mutant.
Yeah.
All right,
let's record this shit.
Still not going to do squats,
but that's fine.